let's be honest border security is a
deadly serious issue look at this
according to the Center for Immigration
Studies since 2001 15 suspected
terrorists they've been apprehended at
our southern border including Islamic
extremists from al-shabaab the Taliban
Isis the true number of terrorist
related crossings is of course
classified likely much higher and
meanwhile over 25 thousand other known
criminal immigrants have been arrested
since 2016 this includes over a dozen
murderers 370 convicted sex offenders
and nearly five thousand individuals
convicted of illegal drug or weapons
charges now of course I would tell you
the vast majority of people that want to
cross the border illegally probably are
people that want a better life for
themselves and their families but even
the illegal immigrants with the best
intentions they are costing we the
taxpayers an enormous amount of money
according to a recent study every
illegal immigrant that successfully
crosses our border costs you the
American people seventy thousand dollars
a year and on December third over three
thousand people were caught illegally
crossing in just one day in November two
year old toddler was found crossing the
border without her parents we must have
the ability to decide who comes into our
country to ensure the safety on both
sides of the border to vet people to
make sure they can take care of
themselves so now more than ever we need
a massive wall it's a common-sense
strategy that actually works keeping
potential terrorists those that are
criminals human traffickers drug
traffickers out of this country illegals
that's a national security issue the
president has long promised now to build
that wall and now he's fighting to do
just that
he's fighting for what's right now he
fought hard this is his history for tax
cuts he gave us the largest tax cuts in
history he fought for new trade deals
and he's winning on that front he fought
back against Obama's endless
bureaucratic regulations and he's
created an environment for businesses
that are now thriving he's fought for
energy independence and for the first
time this week in 75 years we are energy
independent he fought for the
confirmation of qualified originalist
justices and he's won and now he's
fighting for the wall on our southern
border in a big way and confronting
Nancy Pelosi Chuck Schumer for playing
politics with what is the safety and
security of every American citizen take
a look
I'd like not to see a government closing
a shutdown we will see what happens over
the next short period of time but the
wall is a very important thing to us I
might put it a different way border
security is extremely important and we
have to take care of border security
when you look at what happened with the
caravans with the people with a lot of
we shut it down we had no choice we shut
it down but it could be a lot easier if
we had real border security you have a
White House critical you have the Senate
you have the House of Representatives
you have the goal you should pass know
about you because in the Senate we need
60 but I can't excuse me but I can't get
it passed in the house cuz it's not
gonna pass in the Senate I don't always
write fact is you can get it started
that way the house we could get passed
very easy okay and we do but the problem
is the Senate because we need ten
Democrats to vote and Nancy we need
border security is very simple we need
border security people are pouring into
our country including terrorists we have
terrorists we caught ten terrorists over
the last very short period of time ten
these are very serious people our border
agents all of our law enforcement has
been incredible what they've done but we
caught ten terrorists these are people
that were looking to do harm
we need the wall we need more important
than anything we need border security of
which the wall is just a piece but it's
important you just say my way or we'll
shut down the government we have a
proposal that Democrats and Republicans
will support to do a CR that will not
shut down the government we urge you to
take and if it's not good border
security it is very good and if it's not
good border security
I won't take it's what there is when you
look at these numbers of the
effectiveness of our border security and
when you look at the job that we're
doing which is
effective can I be can I tell you
something yeah you just said without a
wall these are only areas we have to we
want to do you have walls Chuck its
effective we you don't have balls it is
not effective we came in here in good
faith and and we're entering into it but
this kind of a discussion in the public
but it's not fair there's you know a new
cold transparency I know it's not
transparency when we're not stipulating
to a set of facts and when we want to
have a debate with you about saying we
confront some is that's it you know what
we need border security that's what
we're gonna be talking about border
security if we don't have border
security will shut down the government
I'm John have called for I will shut
down the government if I don't get my
wool none of us have you know so you say
okay you want to put that who said it
I'll take it okay good you know what
I'll say yes if we don't get what we
want one way or the other whether it's
through you through a military through
anything you want to call I will shut
down the DEP there no and is around and
we disagree I am proud to shut down the
government for border security Chuck Wow
Chuck couldn't even look him in the eye
now tonight we have some breaking news
Fox News has confirmed that House
Republicans are now considering putting
a five billion dollar funding the wall
bill up for that vote that Nancy Pelosi
wants and they'll still fund the
government at current levels now this
bill would prove Nancy Pelosi wrong and
then put Senate Democrats in a pretty
precarious position either from the wall
or they will shut down the government by
the way if you're a Republican in
Congress and you vote no I will tell you
right now we will be highlighting your
name and your record and holding you all
accountable this is about our nation's
security it's about stopping drug
traffickers and human traffickers it's
about safety for the American people
none of this seems to matter to the left
and yet again they're on the wrong side
of what is a monumentally important
issue look at this according to a
Harvard Harris Poll majority of
Americans they support the president the
wall on our southern border seventy nine
percent support a merit-based
immigration system seventy-nine percent
want more secure borders sixty-one
percent say the current border security
is
in adequate and 68% won an end to the
visa lottery system now Democrats don't
want to listen to the American people
maybe they should just listen to
themselves because there's such
hypocrites in the Obama years they
sounded a lot like Donald Trump and
we've got the tape to prove it take a
look I voted numerous times when I was a
senator to spend money to build a a
barrier to try to prevent illegal
immigrants from coming in and I do think
you have to control your borders people
who enter the United States without our
permission are illegal aliens and
illegal aliens should not be treated the
same as people who entered the US
legally the American people will never
accept immigration reform unless they
truly believe that their government is
committed to ending future illegal
immigration those who enter our country
illegally and those who employ them
disrespect the rule of law and because
we live in an age where terrorists are
challenging our borders we cannot allow
people to pour into the US undetected
undocumented and unchecked oh how times
have changed they all sounded like
little baby Donald Trump's now we've
warned you for a long time now Democrats
now they want open borders sanctuary
cities sanctuary states they even want
to get rid of ice and all the hard work
that they do altogether but remember
they want to keep this agenda hidden
which is exactly it was one of the more
fascinating moments during that exchange
with the president that went on eleven
twelve minutes today they kept urging
the president over and over can we talk
privately please please this you're
killing us and sure assigned by the way
they know that they were out of touch
with the American people can we please
do this privately pretty please take a
look the point is is that their equities
to be weighed and we're here to have a
conversation careful way so I don't
think we should have a debate in front
on this again let us have our
conversation number to me with the press
again that's our proposal if it's good
then it's good now and it won't shut
down the dock we can build up a much
bigger let's debate in the private okay
yeah let's debate in Prior we came in
here in good faith and and we're
entering into this kind of discussion no
transparency and let us have a
conversation where we don't have to
contradict in public the statistics that
you put forth but instead it can have a
conversation about what will really work
no let's have the conversation in public
so we can all see where you really stand
instead of working towards a solution
you see it Democrats playing politics
and literally commencing with their
favorite activity bashing Trump
including now moments after that tense
exchange in the White House watch this
the Trump shutdown is something that can
be avoided
that the American people do not need at
this time of economic uncertainty people
losing jobs the market in a mood and the
rest it's a luxury the Trump truck shut
down as the luxury the American people
cannot afford if he sticks to his
position for a five billion dollar wall
he will get no wall and he will get a
shutdown this Trump shutdown this temper
tantrum that he seems to throw will not
get him his wall and it'll hurt a lot of
people because he will cause a shutdown
he admitted he wanted a shutdown it's
hard to believe that he would want that
the president said things are working
quite well at the border well we want to
give him the same thing he had last year
for there working well last year they
should work well this year he shouldn't
shut down the government amazing Chuck
couldn't look him in the eye
when he was right in front of him but he
comes out strong when those cameras are
out there and he doesn't have anybody to
debate or to refute what he is saying
actually chuck the president said he
would own it that he's willing to fight
for his promise for the American people
and that national security is that
important to him okay he says he owns it
accept it
and Nancy Pelosi gets back to the
security of Capitol Hill
she actually then questioned the
president's you can't make this up
manhood telling her fellow Democrats
quote it's like a manhood thing for him
as if manhood could ever be associated
with him this wall thing and according
to the hill she also made this odd weird
bizarre analogy it goes to show you you
get into a tinkle contest with a skunk
and you get tinkle all over you
wow that's the leader of the Democratic
Party soon-to-be Speaker of the House
this is going to be listen you watch in
the first three months of next year this
is going to be entertainment at its
highest level I promise you now let's
contrast those very petty statements to
how President Trump reacted following
the meeting take a look I don't mind
having the issue of border security on
my side if we have to close down the
country over border security I actually
like that in terms of an issue but I
don't want it to be an issue I want it
to be something that what the country
needs it's not really an issue it's
something the country needs it's common
sense the country needs it we need
protection we need border security we
need security from drugs that are
pouring into our country they're coming
in right through that southern border
and we need a wall we need border
security and part of mortor Security's a
wall so I don't mind owning that issue I
mean Chuck's problem is that you know
when the when we glass slows down that
was his idea and honestly he got killed
and so he doesn't want to own it and I
said you know what rather than us
debating who's owning it I'll take it
I'll take it if we close down the
country I will take it because we're
closing it down for border security and
I think I win that every single time
ownership responsibility keeping
promises the courage to fight back while
some criticize the president style this
is why this president was elected it's
why the border wall will get done one
way or the other he is a disruptor in
chief and finally promises are made that
are being kept the very reason the same
reason the president Trump's bipartisan
prison reform bill will also likely pass
Congress and become law soon nonviolent
low-risk
offenders will have the chance to once
again contribute to society without
unreasonably long prison sentences this
is good for America everyone again
nonviolent very important especially
those who are first-time offenders they
should have a chance at redemption now
remember this scene Alice Marie Johnson
who we had the opportunity to meet an
interview thanking the president
thanking the country for a second chance
she spent 20 plus years in prison for
one drug offense nonviolent and now
others like Alice Marie Johnson
currently in prisons they will be given
a second chance
now despite real progress across the
country on multiple fronts well Trump
derangement syndrome has devastated some
of America's worst so-called journalists
of course this includes New York Times
hack Paul Krugman this is the most
insane thing I think I've read in The
New York Times that says a lot
tweeting out an article about how
climate change along with a statement
that reads quote there's a new axis of
evil Russia Saudi Arabia and the United
States okay this is what the New York
Times has become a paper so filled with
anti-trump rage that they employ a
person that's calling the United States
of America evil
not only is Krugman Tain's anti climate
change
Rage absurd it's also misplaced mr.
Krugman in 2017 the u.s. actually led
all countries and reducing carbon
emissions
I guess journalism is not one of his
strengths but what else would you expect
from the New York Times and for the
record Paul no America is not perfect no
country has ever been but there's never
been a country that has accumulated more
power and abused it less and accumulated
more power and used it to help advance
the human condition more than the United
States of America of course you and your
biased
newspaper so-called of record need a
history lesson